- When firms become dominant,
they can become too big to care.
- [Narrator] That's FTC Chair Lina Kahn
at The Wall Street Journal's CEO Council.
She's answering a question
about the Taylor Swift
Ticketmaster Fiasco,
a situation that's renewed calls
to undo its decade-old
merger with Live Nation,
which has plagued Washington, D.C.
and the music industry for years.
Tickets to Swift's first tour
in five years went on sale
to Verified Fans and then
to Capital One card holders.
But in both cases,
a glitchy system kept fans
from securing tickets.
- Once they got into the system,
they'd click on tickets
that would disappear.
They'd get kicked out,
they'd get error messages.
- [Narrator] Which prompted furious fans
to take to the internet.
- What do you mean something went wrong?
I'm not doing this today, Ticketmaster.
- [Narrator] And lawmakers
to call for scrutiny.
- There's no other choice.
That's why we are pushing
the Justice Department
to look at this.
- [Narrator] Before tickets
could open to the public,
Ticketmaster canceled the sale.
So how did Ticketmaster reach
the point where lawmakers
and fans are calling for scrutiny?
Fan testimonies, congressional hearings,
as well as court documents tell the story.
(fans cheering)
Now Taylor Swift fans
are suing Ticketmaster
over claims that the ticketing
giant violated antitrust laws
and some lawmakers are
even calling it a monopoly.
To understand why, we have to go back.
The timeline starts here in 2009
when two of the largest companies
in the live event space
sought to join together.
- Will the combined company
be tempted to divert tickets
to the resale market at inflated prices
because there are now no competitors
to keep this behavior in check?
- Live Nation CEO Michael Rapino,
and then CEO of Ticketmaster
Irving Azoff pled their case
in front of the Judiciary
Subcommittee on Antitrust.
- It was 2009, so this is right
in the thick of the financial crisis.
Concert promotion's a really,
really tough margin business
whereas ticketing, on the other hand,
is a very high-margin business.
- [Narrator] This financial need was one
of the main talking points
at the time for why the
two required a merger.
- I have two choices.
I can hope the economy gets better
or I can seek a more proactive approach
to protect our employees,
reward our shareholders
and better service artists and fans.
- [Narrator] Of course, the committee
also heard the opposing case.
Antitrust law attorney David A. Balto,
as well as some music promoters,
each testified against the merger.
- From a straightforward
horizontal concern,
this merger is anti-competitive.
- The fear was that this
would create this behemoth
that would kind
of have a strangle hold
on the music business.
- [Narrator] That's because Ticketmaster
was already the dominant
ticketing provider
while Live Nation was the
largest promoter of live shows.
Blending the two would mean
the company would have a hand
and pocketbook in nearly every step
of the live event business.
- When you have that type of integration,
it can create certain types
of conflicts of interest.
At the time, there was a concern
that Ticketmaster might use its position
to tie those things together,
and to say, well, in order
to have access to this venue,
you actually have to
use our ticketing site.
- [Narrator] The Department of Justice
ultimately allowed the merger
after coming to an
agreement with the companies
through what is known as a consent decree.
- Under the settlement, it says
that Live Nation is not allowed
to strong arm venues
into using Ticketmaster.
- [Narrator] But almost 10
years later, reports broke
that the DOJ was preparing legal action
for that very reason.
- According to this report,
it believes it violated
a merger settlement
by trying to coerce concert
venues into using Ticketmaster.
- Without Live Nation
admitting any wrongdoing,
a new settlement with the
Department of Justice was reached.
I think a lot of people viewed it
as sort of a slap on the wrist.
- [Narrator] Then as
the Biden administration
took office, lawmakers
like US Representative
Bill Pascrell voiced hope
for stricter antitrust laws.
In a letter to the admin, Pascrell,
along with several other Democrats said,
"The evidence of strangled
competition is overwhelming"
and called on the admin
to revisit the merger.
- We've seen these agencies,
the DOJ and the FDC,
really be encouraged to
take a more critical eye
toward these big mergers.
- [Narrator] As part of a broader effort,
President Biden signed an
executive order last year aimed
at promoting competition
in the American economy.
- Let me be very clear,
capitalism without
competition isn't capitalism.
It's exploitation.
- But that fall, as live
events began revitalizing
from the COVID-19 halt, issues
with Ticketmaster's site
continued to mount.
Similar problems to Swift's Eras tour
happened last year with the BTS concert
and Olivia Rodrigo's too.
Then in December this year,
Ticketmaster apologized again,
this time for a Bad Bunny
ticket fiasco in Mexico City.
♪ I remember it all too well ♪
- [Narrator] In the
current live event market,
it's not uncommon
for a ticketing site to get
overwhelmed with high volume
but this reached an entirely
new scale with Taylor Swift.
- For the first day of pre-sales,
they sold over two million
tickets to her show,
which is the most tickets sold
for any single artist in a single day
in Ticketmaster history.
- [Narrator] Ticketmaster
sold tickets to all
but five of her 52 stadium shows.
The ones at the State Farm Stadium
and the AT&T stadium were
sold through SeatGeek.
That's because of a
business practice known
as exclusive ticketing contracts.
- In that case, Ticketmaster goes
to venues and inks an exclusive deal,
which means anything that
comes through this stadium
or arena is gonna be sold
through Ticketmaster.
- [Narrator] In an interview with CNBC,
Liberty CEO and Live
Nation chairman Greg Maffei
credited the company's stellar services
for its market share.
- Our competitor, who is the
promoter for Taylor Swift,
chose to use us because we
are, in reality, the largest
and most effective ticket
seller in the world.
Even our competitors want
to come on our platform.
- [Narrator] To which Taylor
Swift's promoter AEG rebutted.
- And they said, no, we
actually didn't have a choice.
She's the biggest artist in the world.
She's gonna tour in
stadiums, and those stadiums
are locked up in exclusive
contracts with Ticketmaster.
- [Narrator] Live Nation
has said it didn't engage
in behavior that warranted litigation.
The company added
that the ticketing industry
is more competitive than ever.
- It's pointed to some
of the deals that it's lost in
venues to competing services
and it says that it continues to innovate
and make its technology better.
- [Narrator] The Justice
Department declined to comment.
While calls build for
the DOJ to undo the deal,
many industry experts wonder
if reversing the merge
would solve the issue.
- Ticketmaster would still
be the dominant player
in the ticketing industry.
It would still control some
70 to 80% of the market
and it would still have these
exclusive ticketing contracts
with the venues.
- [Narrator] But undoing the
merge isn't the only option
at the DOJ's disposal.
- They can also do investigations
into whether current business practices
are unlawful under separate laws.
- [Narrator] The legal actions taken
against Ticketmaster and
Live Nation are pending.
In the meantime,
Taylor Swift fans are
scavenging resale sites,
still hoping to secure tickets.
(pensive music)